[Applaudissements]
tu peux pas vraiment ça a l'air top
c'est salir génial mais c'est mort tu
pourras pas pourquoi parce qu'en fait ça
jamais été fait et 20 de temps désolé
mais c'est pas vraiment pour toi tu vaux
est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit ça tu peux
pas j'ai choisi
j'imaginais qu'on avait déjà dit mais ce
truc cette phrase tu veux pas ces trois
mots je les déteste je les déteste j'ai
toujours détesté
et qu'est ce que j'ai entendu genre tu
as une idée de ouf c'est là c'est en toi
et d'un coup genre ben tu peux pas à mes
15 ans je suis rentré un soir du lycée
j'ai déjà mes parents écoutaient je vous
aime mais je vais partir je vais partir
là en fait j'en avais marre j'en avais
marre de ma routine j'en avais marre de
du lycée j'en avais marre de mes amis de
mes parents j'en avais marre de tout
mais enfin j'avais 15 ans quoi alors
curieusement ils m'ont dit
ils m'ont dit non moi je leur ai dit ici
ils m'ont dit non je leur ai dit si cinq
mois plus tard j'étais à 100 barbara en
californie
j'ai pas vous cacher que cette cette
année est seul à des milliers de km 2
c'était très dur mais qu'est ce que
c'était nécessaire
j'ai découvert et confirmer quelque part
mes passions le sport
le yoga le surf et le dépassement de soi
ensuite j'ai dû rentrer en france et les
années se sont se sont enchaînées c'est
un peu c'est un peu triste quand mon
genre enchaîné s'était c'était ça
j'étais serveuse j'étais vendeuse
j'étais ouvreuse dans un théâtre et plus
ça passait plus je me faisais chier
moi j'avais envie de moi j'avais envie
de continuer moi j'étais motivé et un
matin je me suis réveillé je me
rappellerai toujours de ce matin je me
suis réveillé déprimé en fait est ce que
ça vous est déjà arrivé de vous
réveiller vide donc quelques mois sont
passés j'ai eu quelques conversations
avec moi même puis sur saône et voir mes
parents et je leur ai dit bon bah je
repars en californie d'ios est mort
trouver un travail reprend des études
fin tu peux pas moi je leur ai dit ça je
suis retourné en californie et j'ai
quelque part en fait repris ses passions
que j'avais comme un peu mis de côté je
les ai partagé partager mes expériences
sur instagram qu'elles soient positives
ou négatives mais je vais partager
c'était sincère et très naturelle ça
ressemblait je peux vous montrer ça
ressemblait à ça ce que j'avais sur fait
tous les jours en fait voilà ça
ressemblait au cias
c'est là où je faisais du sport donc
j'allais m'entraîner là bas parce que
c'était sympa je crois que le cadre
était cool ça c'est quand je faisais du
yoga dans la rue à los angeles parce que
j'avais à faire et ensuite je vais
poster annonce sur instagram
un jour j'étais à los angeles et
probablement je devais conduire trop
vite en train d'écouter drake ou
kendrick lamar à fond et j'ai eu un
e-mail d'une entreprise de sport qui
ouvraient des salles à paris cette
entreprise c'était dynamo le truc c'est
qu'à la base le le vélo c'était pas ma
passion mais chanter que rentrer en
france
il y avait un truc en moi qui me disait
vas-y fais-le ensuite j'ai compris que
les coaches et dynamos parlait en fait
les coaches et dynamo en fait tu faisais
un de chaud le truc c'est que
j'étais timide de ouf vraiment genre
maladie je veux attendre que même un
droit très de de trembler c'est bon mon
premier passage test chez dynamo c'était
ce qu'on appelle couramment un désastre
en fait quand on fait de la grosse merde
ils m'ont dit et musique sont et musique
seront toit peint par contre faut parler
donc je me suis dépassée
je me suis entraîné j'ai révisé et un
deuxième passage j'ai tout donné
ça fait trois ans que je donne des cours
chez dynamo je suis passé master coach
j'atteins bientôt monde 2000 m court et
a vraiment un truc de ouf dynamo c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'incroyable et à
chaque début de session je sais georges
le sait vraiment que toute la salle et
moi on sent comme ça et c'est juste le
début du cours je vous laisse imaginer
la suite
[Applaudissements]
obama
[Musique]
mais bel est la bougie
m
[Musique]
enfin
may cry mois
aho
m
est-ce que je kiffe le plus vraiment ce
que je peux plus ça c'est ouf
mais ce que je kiffe le plus c'est de
savoir qu'à travers ce que j'ai fait
pour moi à travers ce dépassement de soi
que j'ai eue pour passer cette timidité
je sais que je transmets aux autres dans
la salle
je sais qu'ils se dépassent jeu c'est
petit à petit ils ont plus de en plus
confiance en eux et je les vois et je
les sens je sais qu'ils osent de plus en
plus et ça je vous promets ça pas de
pression cette confiance en soi que m'a
donnée enfin en moi je me donnais le
dynamo m'a permis un m'a permis de
réaliser autre chose que j'avais un
autre projet que j'avais en tête
s'étaient donné des cours de yoga que
j'aimerais prendre les cours de yoga
j'avais vraiment envie de donner du très
intense hip hop yoga donc j'imagine que
quand je vous dis yoga vous pensez
direct quinzaine être calme être relax
limite tu vois le gars il met deep
limite tu fais une sieste tu sais pas
trop mais quelque chose d'assez calme
je pense que si je suis dans vos têtes
maintenant quand vous pensez au yoga
vous voyez à peu près ça
[Musique]
voilà mathias est pas ça tu ailles très
intense hip hop yoga c'est pas ça dans
un courtier y on travaille on travaille
la force la souplesse la concentration
la méditation aussi mais tout ça dans
une salle éclairée à la bougie avec le
beats du hip hop à fond donc si vous
voulez je peux vous le faire je pense
que tu y ailles ça devrait ressembler à
ça
[Musique]
ja
mais c'est
[Musique]
donc prendre le yoga ont séduit pop plus
le fait de peut-être perdre complètement
ma crédibilité
c'était un risque et on m'a dit tu peux
pas on m'a même dit tu n'as pas le droit
pourtant c'est ce que je faisais je le
faisais déjà pour moi c'est comme ça que
je pratiquais j'avais le le hip hop à
fond je bougeais sur l'ebit du hip hop
et c'est ça qui me faisait du bien j'ai
pas non c'est y aller pour faire un truc
qui marche
j'ai vraiment fait pour partager ma
passion partagée ce qui moi vraiment
faisait résonner et pour tout les yogis
où les gens en général qui ont eu des a
priori je pense que tu y ailles a su
montrer qu'une idée complètement
inattendu et à la limite du correct
pouvait faire de la magie
merci vraiment à tous ceux qui ont
visité parce que ça m'a encore plus
donné envie de le faire toutes ses
passions dont je vous parle c'est mes
parents en fait j maison transmises mes
parents étaient passionnés et vivent de
leur passion
mon père était musicien pianiste et
compositeur ma mère était chanteuse
danseuse et hôtesses de l'air grâce chez
air france tous les trains en été où je
savais quand j'étais jeune je me le
disait tous les trois vraiment n'était
top
j'avais tellement chance d'être dans
cette famille ils m'ont vraiment donné
cette passion pour la vie et cette
passion surtout pour vivre la sienne
parce que vraiment on meurt en fait à
mes onze ans mon père est mort devant
moi c'était un matin j'étais en sixième
et il est tombé d'une falaise
quand les pompiers l'ont remonté sur le
brancard
je dis regardez j'espérais voir encore
la vie en lui rien n'allait plus et
malgré cette cette tristesse de ouf
et cette situation irait j'ai regardé
j'ai besoin de lucidité et dans ma tête
je me suis dit en vrai on meurt
alors vraiment faible et tu peux pas
mes parents m'ont donné l'exemple de
vivre passionnés et moi j'ai envie de
transmettre mes passions dans le mot
transmettent à être et sans vouloir me
la jouer paulo coelho dans le mot
transmission émission moi vraiment je
crois aux deux et je crois vraiment
qu'on transmet que ce qu on m a mis onze
ans est cet épisode ce drame aurait pu
être un tu peux pas général mais la vie
m'a comme balancé cette force et cette
envie de me dire si et je vais le faire
maintenant je vous dis tout ça mais une
semaine je me suis dit tu peux pas il ya
semaine je me suis dit tu peux pas faire
c'est éthique ce genre on s'en fout j'ai
pas je n'ai pas fait de l'humanitaire
j'ai pas écrit un roman avec une
histoire incroyable j'ai pas inventé une
formule chimique révolutionnaire mais
peut-être que c'est vous qui le ferait
ou peut-être que vous réaliserez ce qui
résonne vraiment de au fond vous si
encore vous avez ce tu peux pas dans la
tête
mettez la musique à fond et je vous
promets que vous l'entendrez plus il ya
une semaine je me suis dit tu peux pas
tu peux pas faire ce tedx vous savez
quoi je viens juste de faire
j'aurais aimé rester une phrase en tête
ma fille j'ai papier vous pouvez
applaudir ça ne mange pas juste pour
vous dire maintenant si on vous dit tu
peux pas quelque part c'est vrai en vrai
en vain on peut pas on ne peut pas ne
pas le faire les filles
[Applaudissements]